الان لايف مساء الخير على حضراتكم ربنا
يسعد مساكم
الاسئله تيجي على طول انما اهلا وسهلا بس
انا قبل ما ابدا عاوز افتكر انه انا كنت
وعدت حضراتكم بحلقه
لبعض الاصدقاء اللي بيطلبها عن اليمين
واليسار والمفاهيم الاساسي
اثار ليبرالي
محافظ قومي الحمد لله تمت وان شاء الله
سوف تذاع غدا او بعد غير على الاكثر ابدا
باسئله حضراتكم
وهستاذنكم ممكن شرح مبسط لاثبت اليابان في
التسعينات اثبت اليابان في التسعينات يا
عبد الرحمن مشروحه بالتفصيل على قناه نعرف
اقتصاد استاذنك ادخل واكتب اليابان هتلاقي
في حلقتين عن اليابان الازمه مذكوره في
الاتنين لكن في واحده من الحلقتين لا اذكر
العنوان مذكوره بالتفصيل والفقاعه اللي
حصلت في التسعينات والتي او الازمه
الاقتصاديه اللي حصلت في التسعينات ولم
تتعافى منها اليابان حتى الان استاذنك
ادخل واذا شفت الحلقه
وكان عندك اسئله اخرى انا تحت امرك
مرحبا استاذنا ما الذي يدفع
شخص ما ليبذل الغالي والنفيس
وربما ارتكاب مخالفات قانونيه من اجل
الحصول على السلطه لماذا كل هذا الصراع
على السلطه بين الناس وشكرا حيدر هذا
السؤال فلسفي السلطه يا صديقي شوف في
معلومتين ممكن اقول لكم لك انا طبعا انه
الانسان ممكن يتنازل عن امور كثيره احنا
الصوره كويسه
ان الانسان ممكن يتنازل عن اشياء كثيره
لاقرب الناس اليه وهم ابناؤه الا السلطه
يعني من النادر من النادر في التاريخ
انتجت اب يعطي لاولاده كل شيء لكن السلطه
لا لا يعطيها لهم وفي ملوك في دول
ديموقراطيه وفي دول غير ديمقراطيه
ضلوا على عروشهم حتى يعني اهلكهم المرض
ولم يتنازلوا عن السلطه لاقرب الناس الى
قلوبهم ابنائهم
وبالتالي السلطه دي مساله يعني
اغراءها من الواضح لمن جربها انه حاجه
يعني لا تقاوم الملحوظه الثانيه انه دائما
يقال كده ان ده موستن
اكثر غريزه اكثر الاشياء اهميه للناس بعد
البقاء على الحياه اللي هو الاكل والشرب
وكذا يعني هو غريزه ان تكون مهما تبيع
الشعور بالاهميه ده بقى بيختلف من شخص
لاخر شخص عاوز انه يكون ناجح في عمله شخص
عاوز انه يمتلك اموال لكن السلطه احد
الابواب الواسعه التي تمنح الانسان شعورا
بالاهميه وهذا ما اعتقده يعني حيدر
اذا كانت القروض مثل طباعه النقود كلاهما
يزيد التضخم فلماذا الدول تفضل القروض عن
الطباعه ده عبد الرحمن
يعني اصله يعني برضو هي دي قصه انت تقترب
منين كل حاجه انت في الحالتين انت لما
تيجي انت عندك ازمه اقتصاديه دوله عندها
ازمه اقتصاديه هي بتحاول تقترض الاول من
من الداخل من البنوك فاذا انت اقترضت من
البنوك البنوك عندها
ودائع الناس في البنوك هي عباره عن اجباري
مدخرات الناس
مدخره ماندو وسيد
عبد الرحمن الى اخره مدخرات الشركات الى
كله موجود في البنوك فانت اذا اصرفت في
الاقتراض من البنوك معناها ان انا كمستثمر
اللي هيجي عشان يبني مدينه اللي هيبني
عشان مصنع هيجد ان الحكومه قد تغولت على
مدخرات الناس ولم يبقى للقطاع الخاص
المنتج شيئا يقترض هي الحكومه هتاخد
بالفلوس تعمل بها ايه في الغالب هتنفقها
في في رواتب في خدمات الى اخره القطاع
الخاص هيتاثر ويحصل عمليه كراوند فهنا
يعني صعب ان هي تعتمد تماما على الاقتراض
من من البنوك يعني ثم ان في اسباب اخرى
عمليه انه اذا الحكومه بالغت في الاقتراض
من البنوك المؤسسات الدوليه بتعتبر ان هذا
البنك قد مش قد بالضروره يعني قد تسعى
لتخفيض جدرته الائتمانيه لانه كده منكشف
بشكل كبير على حكومه افترض بلد زي المغرب
زي تونس اقترض بشكل كبير جدا من البنوك
الرئيسيه ثلاث اربع خمس بنوك اذا الحكومه
تعثرت عن السادات معناه ان هذا البنك سوف
ينهار فبتمنع البنوك القواعد اللي بتنظم
الجهاز المصرفي عالميا بتمنعه من الاسراف
في اقرات حكومته
طيب يبقى هو هيسعى تاني الايه اذا هو
الساعه ما يقترضش من البنوك ودي يعني شيء
له ايجابيات وسلبياته هيطلب من البنك
المركزي يطبع فلوس اذا طلب فلوس من البنك
المركزي طباعه نقود يعني يبقى في الحاله
ديت هيحصل عمليه تضخم كبيره جدا برضو
القروض بتعمل تضخم والطباعه بتعمل تضخم بس
لكل حاجه مميزات وعيوب ممكن يلجا الى هذا
والنتيجه انه مش هيزاحم البنوك ولكن
الاقتصاد كله قد ينهار نتيجه
[موسيقى]
طباعه النقود ممكن يلجا الى الاقتراض من
الخارج بيلجاوا للاقتراض من الخارج اذا
كان التمويل رخيص
يبقى اوكي يفضله لكن ماذا لو كانت تكلفه
عاليه جدا لن يستطيعوها ثم انه الاقتراض
من الخارج عاده بيكون خطر لانه اذا مر
بازمه اقتصاديه هيكون من الصعب جدا انه
يتحايل على السادات لانه مش هيعرف يطبع
العمله الاجنبيه زي ما بيعمل فيه الدخل
يعني خلاصه الاجابه
ان المساله مش في المطلق ان ده بيعمل لي
تضخم وده بيعمل لي تضخم الدوله عاده
بتقترب من الداخل وبتقترض من الخارج سيبك
من المساله طباعه النقود دي عمليه فاشله
تماما
فهي بتميز ايه الارخص والمتاح وبحاول
بتجمع ما بين الاتنين وبتزيد شويه مع اللي
تكلفته ارخص بتلجا لطباعه النقود لما
بيكون في صعوبه انها تقترب من الخارج ومن
الداخل وطبعت النقود عمليه ماساويه طبعا
خاصه اذا اصرافه اسرافه فيها
مساء الخير استاذ سيد قبيل برايك مصير
المفاوضات السوريه التركيه وهو بيشير الى
اخونا معلش لحظه الاسئله جريت ما شاء الله
الاسئله كثيره جدا
مش عبد الرحمن انا استاذنك انك يعني تبعث
لي تقول لي اذا كنت فهمت ولا اعيد الاجابه
تاني لان انا حاسس ان انا ممكن اكون اثقلت
عليك باجابه طويله مش متاكد مدى وضوحها
بالنسبه لك لو مش واضحه قولي حابب اوضحها
لك يعني اخونا
عبدك اي مساء الخير مصير المفردات السوريه
التركيه
[موسيقى]
يعني التنازلات لننتظر ونرى
محمد بيقول اصبحت روسيا المورد الرئيسي
للنفط للهند والصين بدلا من السعوديه
والعكس صحيح
مع اوروبا هل يؤدي ذلك الى تغيرات سياسيه
بالابتعاد الصين عن الشرق الاوسط لا يا
محمد مش هيحصل ده الصين بلد كبير جدا
وبيستهلك كميات نفط مهوله جدا او كميات
طاقه مختلفه بكل انواع الطاقه ومنها
البترول انما دايما صانع السياسه في بلد
كبير زي الصين في بلاد اصغر من الصين
بيكون حريص انه الا يضع كل بيضه كل بيضه
في سله واحده كما يقولون لانه مثلا لو انه
هو قطع بترول ده يعني افتراض خيالي كل
بترول الشرق الاوسط واعتمد على روسيا
هيكون كده اصبح يعني روحه في ايد روسيا
وهيكرر الخطا اللي عمله الاوروبيين بان هم
ادمنوا الغاز
الروسي على مدار سنوات باعتباره انه مد كل
الشبكات وبقت كل الشبكات تاتي من روسيا
الى اوروبا وعانوا كثيرا في العام ونصف
ولسه المعاناه مستمره بالمناسبه يعني
علشان يحاولوا ينوعوا مصادر الغاز وما
زالت مشكله كبيره في اوروبا فده مش هيحصل
اوروبا خلاص بدات في تنويع الغاز دفعت
الثمن وسوف يظل هذا الثمن يعني مستمر الى
فتره طويله
فيما يتعلق
كذلك الصين
حريصا هي تنوع مصادر الطاقه عندها بحيث ان
هي لا تكرر خطا
الاوروبيين انا حاسس ان الاضاءه ضعيفه يا
ماندو ولا تمام كده
طيب زي الفل تمام اوكي
استاذ سيد المحترم الحكومه المصريه كاشخاص
كالشخص المتحمس جدا لا كده تمام
ويريد تطوير كل شيء في نفس الوقت فيريد
بناء مدينه وقطار حديث واشياء اخرى
فيحمل عشره بطيخات في يد واحده
اسال الله ان لا يسقطها جميعا وحمد الله
مصر رحم الله مصر يا صديقي نتمنى والله ده
اخوانا دراما
القصه بقى يعني دايما هي محل احد احد
القضايا الاساسيه المثاره الان في مصر هل
نحن على الطريق السليم ام في حاجه الى
اعاده ترتيب الاولويات وحقيقه قضيه مش
جديده يعني انما ادعو معاك ان ربنا يحمي
مصر ان شاء الله
استاذ سيد ممكن تحكي عن العلاقه بين ايران
وحزب
وهل العلاقه بدات بسبب تحالفهم على صدام
حسين محتاج ان انا استذكر ما حدث يا صديقي
لانها علاقه ملتبسه
وعلاقه الكرد الكرد اولا من الخطا ان احنا
نقول الكرد طبعا محدد انا عارف انت بتتكلم
على حزب العمال الكردستاني ومحدد علاقه
ايران بيه بس الحقيقه ده يستدعي مني ان
انا احتاج بعد الوقت حتى اتذكر البدايات
لانها برضو مرحله طويله جدا من العلاقات
فسامحني الاجابه فورا ليست حاضره في ذهنه
يعني
انما سوف اخذ بها ملحوظه يران
والعلاقه بينهما اللي بتستخدمه احيانا في
تحالفها كده للضغط على دول اخرى على راسها
طبعا تركيا
ويبقى في المباشره القادم باذن الله
حامد كيف حال استاذنا ربنا يحفظك ربنا
يخليك حامد
عمر مرحبا مرحبا يا صديقي استاذنا الكل في
الصدمه
قال انهم يقولون دمرنا 60 مدرعه اوكرانيه
وفي الحقيقه تكون اثنين
فقط وقال انه قتل اكثر من مئه الف جندي
روسي هو قال كده يستخدم خطاء الطوغرافيه
من الحرب العالميه الثانيه انا مش عارف ان
تحدث عن قتل جنود روس ان هو قتل ممكن يكون
قتل
اه وقال انه قتل اكثر مزبوط كلامك كده
تمام
يعني انا الحياه فاهم ان انت مندهش بس مش
عارف الصدمه جايه منين من الارقام ولا من
خروج او تمرد بروجن فلو تحدد لي السؤال
ممكن تكون المساله ايسر شويه هي عموما
القضيه كلها تطور خطير
اضر روسيا بشده ادر صوره بوتين بشده
واستاذنك لغايه ما توضح لي السؤال انه
البعض كان ارسل لي بل محللين على قنوات
مختلفه يقول لك انه السيناريو اللي
بيرجحوه ان هذا امر متفق عليه بين بوتين
رئيس فاجنر ورئيس بيلاروس لانه علشان
بوتين عاوز يعرف من الصديق ومن العدو
وعاوز يستغل كمان
[موسيقى]
هذه الازمه حتى يرسل جماعه فاجنر بجنودها
وعدتها واعدادها الى بيلاروس تحت سمع
وانظار العالم ثم يهاجم اوكرانيا
يعني مع وافر الاحترام طبعا كل شيء وارد
ولكن هذا احتمال شبه مستحيل لانه على
الاقل ما فيش اي منطق يقول انه رئيس دوله
كبيره يهز صورته بهذا الشكل ويهز صوره
يعني
دولته يسئ الى نفسه بهذا الشكل من اجل هذه
الاهداف التي لا دليل عليها انا في انتظار
توضيحك يا اخونا
مستر سكس ممكن تتحدث عن زياره الرئيس
زياره الرئيس الجزائري الى روسيا رئيسه
زياده الرئيس
الجزائري الى روسيا من حوالي اسبوعين
ثلاثه زياره كانت متفق عليها من عده شهور
واستقروا في مايو ثم تاجلت من اكثر من عده
شهور كمان ولكن ليس هناك امر غريب ابدا في
زياره
يقوم بها الرئيس تبون الى الرئيس
روسيا لانه الجزائر هي اهم حليف له او اهم
صديق لروسيا في منطقه
يعني العالم العربي على الاقل
هي واحد من اكبر مشتري الاسلحه الروسيه
وبالتالي العلاقات قويه جدا بين الاتنين
هو ايه الهدف كانت كلها الهدف المعلنه
كلها مقنعه واحد انه بيتفاوض على مزيد من
الاسلحه
ان كان بيتفاوض على دعم روسي من اجل
الانضمام الى منظمه بريكس اللي هتعقد
اجتماعها التالي في اغسطس في جنوب افريقيا
خصوصا بقى طبعا روسيا في حاجه الى الجزائر
لان روسيا بلد الان
ما اقدرش اقول ان هي معزوله طبعا روسيا
بلد كبير وعندها عدد ضخم من الدول اللي
بيتعاملوا معها ولكن عندها حصار من جانب
الدول الغربيه الغنيه وهي بتدعم كل بقى
تدعم بتقوي كل العلاقات اللي ممكن تقوم مع
الدول الاخرى وعلى راسها على راسها بمعنى
ان الجزائر واحده من اهم حلفائها في
الخارج فهي في حاجه اليها وفي حاجه ان هي
تشتري الاسلحه الروسيه وفي حاجه ان هي
الجزائر تشتري
كل منتجات روسيا لان ده دعم للاقتصاد
الروسي المحاصر من قبل الغرب
الجزائر تحتاج الى روسيا لانه هي
واضح انه هي بخطر التهديد كله بياتيها من
التحالفات المغربيه مع الولايات المتحده
ومع اسرائيل سواء في ملف الصحراء او في
ملف منطقه الساحل كلها
وطبعا شمال افريقيا بصفه عامه وبالتالي هي
كل ما المغرب بيحصل على منظومات تصليح من
اسرائيل والولايات المتحده الجزائر بيسعى
ان يحصل على اسلحه متطوره بنفس القدر يعني
خصوصا مع التوتر العلاقات الجزائريه
الامريكيه من روسيا ومن الصين
السلام عليكم حسن الشمري عليكم السلام
هل كان للسوريا ده اخونا فيصل هل كان دور
مهم في رابع الاحتلال وطعم القضيه
الفلسطينيه هل سيرجع هذا الدور قريبا هل
يمكن تسجيل حلقه عن الحرب الاهليه
اللبنانيه وتبعاتها
لماذا تعتبر حرب العراق لماذا تعتبر حرب
العراق الحرب التي كسرت العرب ده كان
السؤال في بعض يا فيصل يعني اسهل اجابه
فيهم انه هل يمكن تسجيل حلق على الحرب
الاهليه ممكن ان يعني اهتميت بالقصه زي
موضوعات دايما بكلمكم عليها اخد فيها فتره
طويله وبعدين يعني اضعها وهيجي دورها اه
ده ممكن السؤال التاني ليه من ضمن الاسئله
الكثيره التي سالتها يعني ليه تعتبر
غزو العراق في 2003 هي الحرب التي كسرت
ظهر المنطقه العربيه لانه العراق كان بلدا
كبيرا ومهما وزي ما كانوا دايما يقولوا
عليه ان هو حامي البوابه الشرقيه للعالم
العربي بمجرد سقوط العراق اختلت كثير من
الاوضاع كان العراق بيعمل توازن مع تركيا
وبيعمل توازن مع ايران وبيعمل توازن مع
اسرائيل مع دول اخرى زي سوريا وزي الاردن
وزي يعني دول كثيره لما سقط العراق اصبح
مفيش توازن خالص لا مع
الايران مع تركيا وشفنا التركيه وطبعا
سقطت بعد كده الدوله السوريه وتعثرت
فاصبحنا اللي كانت حاجه من الاحلام يعني
انه ايران اللي هي كانت في حرب مريره مع
العراق للتمن سنوات اصبحت صاحبه النفوذ
الاكبر على المؤسسات العراقيه
وبتستهدف في اي وقت اهداف داخل العراق
والدوله العراقيه التي تستطيع ان ترد طبعا
ايران بتقول انا بستهدف يعني اهداف
للموساد داخل العراق اذا صحه الروايه
الايرانيه معناها ان العراق مخترق اذا لم
تصح فان هي بتضرب اهداف والدوله العراقيه
كل ما تستطيع ان تفعله ان تنشط ايران الا
تفعل
تركيا عندها
قواعد متقدمه موجوده داخل الاراضي
العراقيه وبتقوم بعمليات عسكريه داخل
العمق العراقي واحتلت ايضا عشره في المئه
من سوريا يعني طبعا
ادى لخلل كبير جدا نتيجه ان العراق غاب
وطبعا ساءت المساله اكتر بسقوط سوريا
وانتفاء مصر على نفسها بعد ثورات الربيع
العربي انه
بقى
اللاعبين الاساسيين على الشؤون العربيه هي
الدول غير العربيه ايران وتركيا واسرائيل
يعني
وبعدين
يعني يعني الظروف دي حملت دول الخليج اكثر
من طاقتها مع وافر الاحترام لدول الخليج
انه دول الخليج تقدر تلعب بحكم امكانياتها
الاقتصاديه دور مساند للدول اخرى بس ما
تقدرش تقود العالم العربي وتقيم وتقيمه من
عثراته وترسل القوات وجيوش يعني هي تقدر
تقوم بالدور الاقتصادي وكتر خيرهم ان
يعملوهم لكن هي نفسها محتاجه الدول الاخرى
العراق وسوريا ومصر ان هم يدعموهم في
التحديات العسكريه والامنيه اللي بياملوها
بيقابلوها باعتبارهم دول غنيه ومطموع فيها
لكن هي عشان تساعد دول الجوار اقتصاديه
وتساعدهم دبلوماسيا وتساعدهم عسكريا هذا
اكثر مما تحتمل هذه الدول
انت سالت سؤال تاني
دعم سوريا في القضيه الفلسطينيه ده قصه
طويله بقى احنا بنتكلم من يعني على مدار
70 سنه
في النهايه يعني يعني قضيه جدليه لكن
سوريا نفسها كانت طرف في المساله السوريه
طرف اساسي ما الضروره من الاحتلال
الاسرائيلي
وبالتالي هي كانت في المعسكر المتضرر من
اسرائيل قوتها اكيد بعمل القضيه
الفلسطينيه وهي استضافت فصائل فلسطينيه
كثيره جدا دعمتهم في فترات وحاربتهم في
فترات ولكن يعني كان قوتها في كل الاحوال
دعمه للقضيه الفلسطينيه بلا شك
الجزائر روسيا حاضر انت عاوزين حلقه عن
الجزائر روسيا
لماذا الدول الاوروبيه دول مصدره بالرغم
من عملتها المرتفعه بمعنى اخر ليه مع
العولمه عبد الرحمن ده عبد الرحمن واضح
انه بدرس اقتصاد لماذا الدول الاوروبيه
الدول المصدره بالرغم من عملتها المرتفع
بمعنى اخر مع العولمه
الشركات للدول في حاجه
ليه ما تذهبش تقريبا الشركات للدول منخفضه
العمله اذا كنت فهمت سؤالك دول الاوروبيه
يا صديقي مساله انخفاض العمله
في مساله الصادرات عامل
مهم بس مش هو العامل الوحيد يعني انت لما
لو نفترض انه بلد زي المانيا بيصدر سلعه
بيصدر اجهزه كمبيوتر وهنفترض انه بلد زي
بنجلاديش بيتصدر اجهزه كمبيوتر انخفاض
قيمه العمله عامل لكن كمان الجوده عامل
يونيك انك متفرد في سلعه تانيه عامل فانت
بتتكلم على دول كبيره زي المانيا زي فرنسا
زي اسبانيا زي ايطاليا دي دول عندها قدرات
صناعيه ضخمه جدا واحيانا بتقدم سلعه لا
تستطيع دول اخرى تقديمها وعليه فانت
العمله مش هي العامل الوحيد ثم انت لازم
في الاطار العام انت ما بتتكلمش دلوقتي هل
انت مثلا كان عندك جهاز كمبيوتر الماني
وبنفس جودته مع الصيني ولقيت ان الجهاز
الالماني كان ارخص ما هم تغلبوا على
الجهاز الصيني كان ارخص ما هم تغلبوا على
القصه ديت بان التكنولوجيا الاوروبيه او
الغربيه ابتدات تستعين بالمصانع اللي
موجوده في الصين علشان تخفض من انتاجيتها
فكثير من المصانع الاوروبيه موجود في
الصين بالدرجه الاولى موجود في شرق اسيا
بصفه عامه بالدرجه الثانيه موجود حتى لو
كانت صناعات يعني يمكن توطينها في دول
عربيه زي الصراعات الاسمده وصناعات الغاز
اللي هي ملوثه موجوده خارج اوروبا في
المانيا كحكومه ما هياش هي اللي بتستثمر
هي شركات والشركات بتشوف انا عندي منتج
مناسبا في المانيا اوكي مش مناسب هي بتعمل
للدول الاخرى
عشان تنافس بالاسعار الصيني وغيرها
وبالمناسبه المانيا اقامت نهضتها على
ثلاثه دول الدوله الاولى الولايات المتحده
التي كفلت لها الامن وبالتالي ريحتها من
فكره الانفاق العسكري ميزه وفيها عيب
الدوله الثانيه هي كانت روسيا التي وفرت
لالمانيا الغاز الرخيص لسنوات طويله جدا
الدوله الثالثه هي الصين اللي استقبلت
المصانع الالمانيه والشركات الالمانيه
وانتجت
منتجاتها باسعار رخيصه
كل سنه وانت طيب استاذ سيد
عندي سؤالين كيف تفسر الاداء لهذه الروسيا
في حربها ضد اوكرانيا من خسائر فادحه
وتمرد من الشات فاجنر وانضمام فنلندا الى
حلف الناتو ده عبد الرحمن مصطفى اولا كل
سنه وحضرتك طيب شكرا جزيلا يا عبد الرحمن
انا مش عارف اذا كانت روسيا ادائها هذه
ولا لا يعني ده محتاج
فرديه محتاجه فحص
يعني ممكن اقول لك انا طبعا بفكر معاك
بصوت عالي واحد احنا لازم نقرر روسيا
بالدول الكبيره هل هنا ده مش دفاع عن
روسيا انا بفكر معك يعني انا لما اجي اقول
ان روسيا ادائها هزيل ممكن ده يكون فرديه
جيده اذا كانت روسيا تواجه اوكرانيا وحدها
لكن ما حدث انه هل اداء روسيا بالنظر الى
الاعترافات
المسموح مسموع بها والمؤكد عليها من كل
دول العالم انها تواجه حلف شمال الاطلسي
الذي يمد اهم شيء بالاستخبارات من كل دول
حلف شمال الاطلسي ليلا ونهارا وبالسلاح
وبالتمويل والدعم السياسي والدعم العسكري
هل اداء روسيا بعد سنه ونصف من وجهه حلف
شمال الاطلسي يكونوا هزيلا طيب ده واحد
اتنين هل اداء الولايات المتحده في الحروب
المماثله حين كانت في العراق حين
ذهبت الى افغانستان
على مدى 20 سنه حين كانت لها مغامرات اصغر
في الصومال هل كان اداء القوات المسلحه
الامريكيه اعظم مشرف كاسح مثلا ده سؤال
تاني
السؤال النقطه السائل التالته ان الحقيقه
برضو يعني التوضيح انه في حاجه في روسيا
تستدعي الدراسه دايما ادائها
دايما في حاله من التخبط في كل تقريبا حرب
بتدخلها وهذا التخبط بيستمر لفتره ثم في
الغالب بتنتصر
يعني مثلا لو دخلنا مثالين في الحرب
العالميه التانيه ادائها في حرب الشتاء ضد
فنلندا كان اداء استمر عده شهور كان اداء
هزيلا جدا وفنلندا كادت تهزم الاتحاد
السوفيتي العملاق في الشهور الاولى ثم
[موسيقى]
انا اسف ان الكلام قد يبدو لكن هذا مجرد
برين ستورمنج يعني انا اشاركك بانه يعني
انا لا اشاركك اسف لانه الاداء حزين ولكن
اشاركك في شيء تاني انه الروس دفعوا دفعا
الى مصيده وان المصيده ديت يعني مكلفه جدا
للروس ولكن
لست متاكدا من ان الغرب يعني قد
احسن قرار ايقاع بلد بحكم روسيا في هذه
المصيده لانه النتائج على الغرب ليست
قليله ودي قصه محتاجه بحث يعني النتائج
هتكون ايضا خطيره على المدى البعيد على
الولايات المتحده وعلى دول حلف شمال
الاطلسي ودي قصه ممكن نتحدث عنها في وقت
لاحق بالاسهاب يعني
بالطو اذا كنت قرات الاسم صح يا ريت
تكتبوا اساميكم بالعربي يا جماعه او
بالانجليزي ماذا يحدث في مصر وكيف وكيف
سيكون تاثير ما يجري على العرب ماذا يحدث
في مصر يعني اقتصاديا ولا سياسيا مقصديا
احنا اتكلمنا عليه كتير مصر عندها ازمه زي
دول اخرى كثيره يعني
وبتبحث عن حلول لها يعني الجانب السيء
انها ازمه كبيره الجانب الايجابي انها
يعني مصر مش حاله فريده في المساله ديت
بتشارك دول اخرى كثيره في هذه الايام انها
بتعيش في ازمه فلو تحدد السؤال انا تحت
امرك
ما رايك في الاقتصاد المغربي محتاج دراسه
الاجابه محتاجه دراسه يعني علشان نتكلم
عنها بشكل جيد يعني ليه ما فيش حلقات عن
الفلسفه كريم
اللي كان بيسال عن المغرب اخونا سعيد
محتاج يعني نطلع الارقام بتاع الاقتصاد
المغربي
بحيث يكون الاجابه مبنيه على ارقام يعني
يعني الحساب الجاري نسبه العجز
[موسيقى]
العجز في الموازنه اللي هو موجود يعني
نسبه الدين الداخلي والخارجي محتاجين يعني
نسبه استقطاب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه قد ايه
الى اخره
حلقات عن الفلسفه كريم هو فيه يعني انت
بتتكلم فيه ما مضى فيه ولا ايه ده في
حلقات كثيره عن الفلسفه لانه الكلام عن
السياسه
لما تدرسوا بعمق هو كلام عن الفلسفه مش
قصدي يعني من قبيل انه الكلام عن الكره
فلسفه يعني مش قصدي كده يعني انا قصدي
فعلا كلام عن الفلسفه لانه انت لما بتيجي
مثلا يا ماندو عاوز تقول انه اوروبا
انه الولايات المتحده دوله ليبراليه طب
انت عاوز تعرف هي الليبراليه ايه ومين
اسسها من من الفلاسفه اللي الامريكان او
الاوروبيين خدوها لما تقول ان في تيار
محافظ وبالمناسبه الحلقه اللي بكلمكم
عليها اليمين واليسار
وخمس كلمات الاهم في السياسه كل كلمه
وراها فلسفه الكلام اللي انا اتكلمت عليه
كله فيما يتعلق بالعقد الاجتماعي وفلسفه
العقد الاجتماعي لما اتكلمنا هل العربي
يكرهون الديمقراطيه ام انهم غير مستعدين
لها في الاخر كله كلام في الفلسفه الحقيقه
يعني لكن حاضر والله انا كان عندي فكره
اكثر طموحا انه استضيف بعض اصدقائي
المتخصصين في الفلسفه
ونتكلم على
قضايا كلها فلسفيه يعني ولكن لم اوفق يعني
في انه
في القصه ديت ما لقيتش يعني من اصدقائي
وقتها يعني اللي كان مستعدين يتعاونوا معي
بالشكل اللي يناسب قناه على يوتيوب يعني
عنده قدره انه يكثف ويقول كلام منضبط
عميقه وبسيط في نفس الوقت في 20 دقيقه
مثلا يعني لكن حاضر يعني نبذ القصاره
جهدنا باذن الله باذن الله احمد السلام
عليكم كيف استطاعت الجزائر موازنه علاقتها
بين الشرق والغرب
مش الجزائر بس يا احمد مش الجزائر بس اللي
وزنت علاقتها بين الشرق والغرب في طفره في
العلاقات او في اداره الشؤون الخارجيه في
الدول العربيه اللي خرجت عن الطوق وما
عادتش دول زي ما كان في الاذهان انها دول
ستلايت يعني دول تابعه دول الخليج بتدير
علاقتها بشكل جيد جدا بين الشرق والغرب
مصر كويس جدا بين الشرق والغرب دوله
ماذونه زي تونس مش مصره على ان هي ما
تكونش كده وخلاص مع الغرب لا الحقيقه
الهند مثالهم هائل جدا على اداره علاقتها
بين الشرق والغرب لا فالجزائر بلد ردا بقى
على سؤالك هي ليست وحدها بالمناسبه المغرب
رغبه تحالفها الكبير مع الاتحاد مع امريكا
واسرائيل كانت حريصه الا تخسر روسيا باي
شكل من الاشكال وسعه الى هذا التوازن في
طفره تدعو للبهجه في كثير من الدول
العربيه ان هي المره الا تكون في معسكر
كما كان من قبل اما زي الجزائر دوله غنيه
بثرواتها الطبيعيه اللي كله محتاج انه
يتعاون معها على اساس الا تعاقبه بحرمانه
من هذه الثروات وبقت الدول العربيه عندها
الجراه انه سواء جزائر المغرب انا بدل
الكارتين يعني ان هم يعاقب الدول
الاوروبيه فورا اذا هذه الدول العربيه
اغضبتها اعاقبهم بفتح محابس الهجره
يعاقبهم بقطع امدادات الطاقه يعاقبوهم
باغلاق الاسواق الى اخره يعني
مرحبا اخي الفاضل ما هي اكثر الافلام التي
تحبها وتجدها عميقه
وملهمه على فكره انا احب المراه السوداء
لك مرر المراه السوداء فهي سلسله عميقه
جدا
ومهتمه بالمستقبل ارجو ان تلقي نظر عليها
حاضر انا يعني
بلاك ميرث حاضر انا بحب افلام ايه ههه
انا بحب افلام
خالص مليش في الخيال العلمي خالص
السياسيه مثلا
والله يعني هو سؤال جميل لا
انا عموما يعني اصل انا بقى انا ضحكت كمان
لان انا
يعني انا لما اجي اشوف مثلا دراما
وبعدين اقترحها على اولادي اولادي الثلاثه
انا عندي بنتين وعمر الكبير يعني في
العشريناتهم طبعا يعني هم اولادي فاقترح
عليهم دراما فما الاقيش اذان صغير خالص
يعني لكن ما يتفرجوش ليه قالوا لي ما احنا
عارفين انت تتفرج عليها تكون بقى دراما
ايه عامله زي وثائقي يعني احنا عاوزين
حاجه كده تكون افضل
والله بيتفرجوا على حاجات لها معنى برضو
بس احيانا يبدو الحاجه اللي احرجتني جدا
ان انا لقيت مسلسل
اظن هندي نسيت اسمه دلوقتي اعجبني جدا جدا
12 حلقه بس
ناسي اسمه فعجبني جدا ورشحته لكل اصدقائي
ولا واحد
الهنديه دراما عندهم دراما غريبه حلوه قوي
قوي قوي ده كان هندي اوروبي 12 حلقه انا
اسف اسمه غابه عن ذهني ولكن انا اقترحته
بمناسبه اولادي اليوم فما حدش يتفرج عليه
خالص فقلت لهم ليه ده عظيم جدا قلت لهم
بالمناسبه انا بدور على الجزء التاني
ففتحت بسرعه المسلسل هيجي منه الجزء
الثاني امتى لقيت انه قامت الشركه بالغاء
الجزء الثاني لعدم نجاح الجزء الاول
فقالوا لي المشكله فيك انت بطل
على عموما اخواننا انا
مش شايفك انا اسف مش عارف اقرا الاسم
ما هي فرص العمل لخارجي ماجستير العلوم
السياسيه
في انهي بلد يعني
اذا كان معه ماجستير في العلوم السياسيه
وشاطر فعلا ولا واخد مجرد رساله اصل الناس
اللي بياخدوا الرسائل في الماجستير
والدكتوره للاسف الشديد في بعض الدول يعني
بيضاف الى لازم يكون شاطر جدا ولازم يكون
انا مش عارف طبعا بتتكلم على انهي بلد في
بلاد ممكن يكون عنده فرصه انه يعمل يعني
في مجالات البحث وفي مجالات العمل
الممارسه في الدواليب الدوله يعني اذا
كانت الخارجيه او اذا كانت اجهزه الحكومه
المختلفه او في المجالات البحثيه او في
الكتابه كده كتيره يعني بس مش عارف انهي
دوله انت بتتكلم عليه بس لازم يكون شاطر
اصل انت ايه يعني مع عوافر الاحترام انت
بتعمل رساله يعني بحث انت بتقول انا دكتور
على عيني وراسي
انت عامل بحث كويس في الموضوع ده مش كافي
وللاسف الشديد انه كثير من حمله الماجستير
والدكتوراه نتيجه ظروف كتيره في العالم
العربي احيانا بيعمل رسايل ممكن ياخد
عليها درجه بس ما تفتش حد يعني انا فاكر
كويس جدا انه بعض الاساتذه مثلا اخذوا
رسايل ماجستير ودكتوراه عن انهار في
الولايات المتحده ازاي مشاكل النهر ده
كانت ايه ببساطه لان اللتريتشر او
المعلومات متوفره عن اللي موجود في امريكا
او فرنسا او كذا انما المشاكل اللي خد
دكتوراه هنا عن مشكله تخص مثلا السودان
تونس وخد فيها رساله كويسه والبحث ده ممكن
يؤدي الى تغيير سواء في علوم السياسه او
غيره مش كتير قوي ودول بيبقوا ناجحين
حضرتك طلبت المره الماضيه ان نلتزم بموضوع
الحلقه يا ريت تحكي لنا في اول عشر دقايق
في كل لايف مختصر عن احداث هذا الموضوع
لكي نعرف معلومات اكثر من ثم نساله على
اساسه انت عندك حق يا
وحاب بس انا الحقيقه المره دي والمره
الماضيه لم احدد موضوعا لسببين او لسبب
رئيسي يعني انه انا كان قصرت في الاجابه
على اسئله على فترات كثيره جدا فقلت ان
المره اللي فاتت وهذه المره تكون مفتوحه
لمن لم اتمكن من الاجابه على اسئلتهم لكن
في مرات بنبقى عاملين استفتاء وهذا ما لم
افعله هذه المره والمره اللي فاتت للسبب
اللي انا قلت لحضرتك وبيبقى موضوع محدد
فان شاء الله نحدد موضوع يعني في المرات
المقبله اذا ما كانش عندنا اسئله كتيره
متاخره
ونلتزم بيه اما المريض المره دي والمره
اللي فاتت كان الهدف انه يجيب على اكبر
عدد ممكن من اسئله الاصدقاء اللي اشتكوا
ان اسالتهم لا تجاب
وقولوا لي لو كان ده مش حابينه بلغوني
يعني هل ما حدث في روسيا يعتبر اهانه
شخصيه لبوتين
مش عارف يعني يعني اكيد اهتزت صورته كثيرا
يعني
الاهتزاز الصوره ديت بانك انت بتتكلم يعني
على انه مش ان في حد يتمرد ان حد يتمرد
ماشي لكن انه يتمرد ويكون هذا الشخص اصل
الاهانه مركبه يعني واحده انه
انه ده كان مقرب الى بوتين كان من الدائره
القريبه منه
المهين الحقيقه انه برضو رئيس دوله
المعلومات المتوفره تقول ان الراجل ده
يعني كان كروك كان فج كان يعني شخص كده من
يعني ما انتاش بتقرب جنبك يعني مثلا جنرال
شهير مش بتقرب رجل اعمال ناجح مش بتقرب
مستثمر عظيم انما ده راجل يعني كان
يعني خلفيته مش مشرفه قوي ثم هذا الرجل
تمكنه الى ان ينقلب عليكم وتتوقعش كتير من
بروجن يعني انا لما شفته من ضمن الدروس
يعني الواحد بيتعلمها يتامل هذا البروجين
تفتكر الكلمه الشهيره في مصر لما يقول لك
العلم نور يعني ده كان بيفكر بايه لما عمل
هذا الميوتن او هذا التمرد هو اكيد عنده
حساباته تتكشف لنا مع الوقت لكن هل هو كان
متخيل انه هذا التمرد كان هيسرق انه يوصل
لغايه موسكو مثلا او ما يصلش لغايه موسكو
ويعود ادراجه ويعفو وعفا الله عما سلف ما
ده معناه انه سقفه في التفكير برضو محدود
ما يجيبوش لاكثر من كده يعني
مستوى الثاني من من الاساءه لبوتين انه
انت عندك في علامات استفهام كيف مر هذا
الرجل ليه حوالي 800 كيلو في العمق الروسي
ما في علامات استفهام فيعني
الاجابه المختصره نعم
اكبر مشكلات مصر هي زياده السكانيه
فلماذا لم تتخذ الدوله اجراءات حقيقيه
لالزام المواطن بحد اقصى للمواليد او على
الاقل حركه توعويه كبرى ده ابراهيم
اخونا ابراهيم الكلام ده انا
يعني انا كنت اطلعت مره كده يعني على
يعني مره ممكن اطلعكم عليها ولكن القدير
المطروحه من سنه سته وعشرين 1926 يعني من
كم سنه دلوقتي
لماذا لم تتخذ الدوله الدوله لجات في
فترات وعجزت في فترات وكان العائق الاساسي
هو انه
مهما الدوله عملت مش دايما الدوله بتعمل
اللي عليها يعني الدوله احيانا قليله
الكفاءه مش قادره تعمل ده زي مش قادره
تعمل حاجات كتير انما لما ساعدت وعملت جاب
التاثير التاثير ده كان يعني احيانا بيكون
معقول وجيد واحيانا تانيه لا لان في
اعتبارات اخرى وهي الثقافه الدينيه اللي
انت مهما تقوله في التلفزيون ممكن
شيوخ المساجد الاكثر تاثيرا على الناس
اذا كانوا بيقوموا الفكره ديت فطبعا
تاثيرهم بيكون كبير جدا الامر الثاني ان
توعيه الدوله
بتستهدف تقريبا الناس اللي هم عندهم وعي
باهميه تنظيم الانجاب اما الاغلب اما
الاغلبيه من المصريين اللي هم الاكثر
انجابا فهي الفئه الاقل تعليما الاقل وعيا
اللي هي عاده لا تتعرض ولا
يعني مش معرضه او مش بتقرا كتير علشان
تستوعب ده مش مش بتشوف هذا النوع من
الماده
التوعويه يعني
دائما اسمعك تقول انك سجلت الحلقه
الفلانيه ولكنك لم تنشرها
لسبب ما هل تستطيع ان اطلب منك بكل لطف
واحترام ان تطلب كل الحلقات المحفوظه حتى
ولو لم تكن مكتمله وسوف نتقبل ونتفهم عدم
اكتمالها
حاضر انا يعني انا هدي لك مثال عشان تعرف
انا قصدي ايه الحلقه اللي انا سجلتها خلاص
عن اليمين واليسار
انا احيانا بيكون في اكتر من سبب السبب
الاولاني انه حلقه اليمين واليسار اللي
انتم تسمعوها في اقل من 30 دقيقه بلا
مبالغه اخذت مني شهور طبت مني شهور في ايه
انا ما عملتش معجزه يعني المعلومات موجوده
والقصه ما هياش يعني ما هياش معجزه
الشهور دي مش ان انا قاعد متفرغ لها ولكن
انا حطيت الفكره على الورق عاوز استوفي
امور اساسيه احيانا الامور الاساسيه فعلا
مش متاحه في المعلومه عاوزها يعني عاوز
تعرف سبب ضعف اليسار في العالم العربي
مثلا عاوز تعرف سبب انتشار اليمين في
العالم العربي العالم الاسلامي عاوز تعرف
موقف الاسلام من اليمين واليسار اسئله
صعبه مش بالضروره اقولها كلها بس احيانا
بتلاقي ان فيها صعوبه في استقصاء
المعلومات وبعد ما تستغسل معلومه عاوز
تتاكد ان انت تبسطها بشكل ما يكونش صعب
اسمع الحلقه وهتشوف اذا كان رايي واضح ولا
لا احيانا تانيه باخد كثير زي
حلقات يعني اخذت وقت كتير وبعد ما
استكملها لان الوقت تجاوزها زي مثلا
الحرب العراقيه الايرانيه خدت منه جهد
كتير بس كان الوقت عداها انا كنت عايز
اطرحها فيهم مناسبتها فيعدي عليا مثلا
فاقول السنه المقبله على كل الاحوال حاضر
ان شاء الله باذن الله نعمل هذه الامور
جنرالات روس متقاعدين يعملون مع بدر لديهم
امتدادات في الجيش الروسي
ساهموا وعلموا بان الجيش لن يتحرك لانه
ساخط على قرار
الحرب اعتقال بوتين اهم رجل في الجيش
سرفقين يدل على التخبط في الاداره الروسيه
لا شك في ذلك لينا لا شك في ذلك شك في ذلك
ان هناك خبايا كثيره بتدل على انه
روسيا في مازق كبير يعني
انت بمناسبه
اخونا سيرفا بتقول الحلقات الحلقه دي انا
سجلتها بالفعل وبعد ما سجلتها
يعني انا سجلتها يوم الخميس يوم الجمعه
حصل الانقلاب بتاعها او التمرد بتاع
بروجوش اه والله هذا حصل يعني حلقه سجلتها
على انه ازاي الغرب بيخطط الى يعني اضعاف
روسيا او نظريه المليار السعيد ولكن لقيت
انه هيبقى يعني انا سجلتها النهارده الحدث
اتغير كان لا يمكن اذاعه دون الاشاره الى
الحدث الجديد
كلامك مزبوط يا لينا مرحبا سيد جبيل هل
هذا الوقت المناسب للدول العربيه
للتوقيع
للتوقع في الساحه الدوليه مثل اردوغان
واللعب على الحبال للحصول على اكبر قدر من
الفوائد ايوه طبعا طبعا يا وسام بس ده
حاصل بالفعل الدول اللي عندها قدره على
المناوره هي اللي عندها حاجه تقدمها يعني
لما قلت لكم اللي عندها فوائد زي قطر وزي
الامارات وزي السعوديه عندها فوائد دي
بتشجعها لديها ان الناس طمانين فيها نفسهم
الامريكان ياخدوا الاستثمارات دي الصين
عاوزين الاستثمارات ديت الهندي اللي اخوف
عندها قدره على المنوره
الدول اللي عندها مثلا زي الجزائر عندها
ثروه موجوده دوله عندها موقع مهم زي
المغرب بتفاوض عليه المغرب بتفاوض عليه
اسبانيا
[موسيقى]
وفرنسا وغيرهم يعني
دول ماذونه يعني
تعيس جدا الى الحد ان هي مش في الوضع اللي
هي تناور هي في الوضع اللي بتحاول تسترضي
فيه الجميع
من حيث الاجابه العامه نعم كل الدول
مادامنا اصبحنا في
عالم يعني في اتجاهه الى ان اكون متعدد
الاقطاب بتكون في فرصه الى القوى الصغيره
والمتوسطه اللي فايقه اللي واقفه على
رجليها ان هي تناور وتستفيد من كل الفرص
اللي متاحه لكن الدول اللي هي ظروفها
تعيسه هتنور بايه بقى قدرتها على المناوره
محدوده السلام عليكم ورحمه الله ابو احمد
سيد ممكن تتكلم عن الاقتصاد العماني
حاضر
الاقتصاد العماني
والمغري اكثر في العمال ان احنا نتكلم على
الدور اللي باتت يعني تحتكروا في دول
بتحاول تنافسها فيه في ان هي تكون عاصمه
المفاوضات في العالم العربي يعني كل عام
وانت بخير يا ساده جبير ربنا يخليك عبد
الله اللي كان سالني عن الاقتصاد العمري
محمد بادي شكرا جزيلا عبد الله حلقه
حلقاتك المرتبه والمجهزه لها مسبقا قلت
جدا ليه لما قالتي احمد انا متوسط العدد
حوالي خمس حلقات في الشهر
اربعه او خمسه يعني فمعقول يعني بمعدل
الحلقات اللي انت بتصفها ان هي المرتبه
والمجهزه لها مسبقا اللي هي غير المباشر
يعني اربعه او خمسه على نعرف الام
وحوالي اربعه او خمسه على نعرف اقتصاد
بالاضافه الى مرتين على الاقل مباشره
اعتقد انها هي معقول يعني وزي مره مره
تانيه بقول لك احمد انه
الحلقات بتاخد وقت كتير علشان تكون يعني
فيها حاجه يعني
رايك في احتجاجات الحاليه في فرنسا لا ما
عنديش راي والله يا اخونا يعني انا ما
عنديش راي غير ما عنديش راي مختلف عن
الاخرين يعني ما عنديش حاجه
اضيف بها خلاف انه يعني فرنسا زي الدول
اللي فيها يعني
مشاكل تاريخيه
طبيعي ان هذه المشاكل سوف تطاردها كثيرا
بالمناسبه كان في مره مسؤول فرنسي بيقول
انه اظن ايام سركوزي كان بيقول ان الرئيس
القادم الجديد اللي هو كان سركوزي وقتها
مقسم العالم العربي الى ثلاث مناطق دول
الغنيه دول الفائض وهذه على على راس
اولوياته يعني ايه الدول اللي عندها فلوس
اللي هي دول الخليج العراق اللي عندها فرص
استثمار ثم دول الصداع التاريخي يعني
الدول اللي العلاقه متوتره هو في حاجه
اليها لكن العلاقات معقده جدا زي الجزائر
والمغرب ثم الدول الاخرى اللي هي الدول
المتعثره اقتصاديا وهذه لا يهتم بها فقط
بروتوكولات يعني زياره كذا بروتوكوليه كل
فتره
هل يمكن ان تصبح الهند بديل امني للولايات
المتحده في الشرق الاوسط لا مستحيل يا
صديقي
يعني الهند دوله دورها بيزيد كل يوم لكن
علشان تصبح دوله تقوم
بما تقوم به الولايات المتحده اللي هي
عامله زي الاخطبوط وعندها 30 الف جندي
باسطول الخامس واساطيل اخرى قريبه وعندها
استعداد ان هي زي ما بيقولوا كده عندها
فنجر ان صباع في كل فطيره وتدعم هذا
النظام وتقلب هذا النظام وتتدخل في
الوساطه ديت تحتاج الى سنوات طويله جدا
جدا جدا ولا تنسى ان الهند مع عوافر
الاحترام هذه الدوله العملاقه مليار و400
مليون انسان ناتج المحلي الاجمالي لها حتى
الان بنتكلم على حوالي ثلاثه تريليون اما
تزيد هتبقى كام اربعه تريليون خمسه
تريليون هتبقى اقل من اقتصاد الياباني
يعني
لسه قدامها مسافه طويله جدا ان هي تخفف من
حده الفقر اللي على اراضيها انا اسف انا
هقف على على يعني على الساعه العاشره
يعني حتى لا اقف بشكل مفاجئ يعني
استاذ سيد ما هي فرص دخول
استاذ سيد ما هي فرص دخول تركيا للاتحاد
الاوروبي وما المتوقع طلب فرص دخول تركيا
للاتحاد الاوروبي تكاد تكون شبه مستحيله
يعني المساله اغلقت من فتره طويله يعني
وما المتوقع من طلب السيد اردوغان الحديث
لقبول طلب تركيا للالتحاق بالاتحاد ما
اعرفش انه اردوغان جدد الطلب يعني انما
التحاق تركيا
بالسعو سنوات وادركوا ان الاتحاد الاوروبي
لن يقبل تركيا وبصراحه قالوا الاجابه يعني
انه احنا انه التحدي الاوروبي هذا نادي
مسيحي
مش بمعنى الناس بيروحوا كنائس يعني لا
يعني احنا دوله اتحاد كده لهاويه وثقافه
وده كان في البدايه ثم بقى بعد كده لما
ابتعدت تركيا قوي الاول كانت عندها مشاكل
في الاقتصاد حسن الاقتصادهم فتره قالوا لا
والله عندنا مشاكل معكم في واحد اتنين
تلاته قوانين العمل لا قوانين مش عارف
الاعدام لا قوانين
يعني تجاوف امور كثيره ثم كان في اتجاه
داخل اوروبا لان احنا نادي مسيحي ومش
هندخل دوله واحده فيها حوالي 80 مليون
مسلم يعني
وبعدين نلاقي عندنا يا جماعات اسلاميه
ونلاقي عندنا كذا صعب علينا يعني
ما اعرفش انت انت بتقول لي حاجه يعني
معرفش مصدر معلومتك انه عنده طلب حديث
يعني ما اعرفش ان اردوغان جد الطلبه ابدا
لدخول الاتحاد الاوروبي
جايز وانا معرفش ممكن شرح مبسط لازمه حقل
الدره عاوز حلقه يا صديقي
ومره تاثيره على العلاقات الخليجيه
الايرانيه حاضر حقل الدره
هو الجديد في حقل الدره ده ده حقل يعني
كان ما بين الكويت والسعوديه لكن هي الفكر
وعلى فكره القصه موجوده من سنين طويله من
عشرات السنين انما الجديد في المساله
الايران دخلت على الخط وبتقول انا ليا جزء
من هذا الحقل وعندها تصور انه هذا الحقل
بشكل ما جزء منه وقع في اراضيها فدي قصه
تبقى مساله تحكيم يعني ما بين الدول لكن
يعني التفاصيل تحتاج ان الواحد يطلع على
ايه راي ايران في القصه يعني وزي ممكن ان
هي
ممكن تحل مع الايرانيين كقضيه يعني من ضمن
القضيه الخلفيه
استاذ سيد لدي سؤال بما ان السعوديه رابطه
عملتها بالدولار عملتها قربت عملتها
بالدولار
ده بيخليها لو رفعت سعر الفائده عن امريكا
انها تجذب رؤوس الاموال اكثر بكثير من
امريكا ليه ما تعملش كده لو عملت كده
فطبيعي انه نتيجه زياده الطلب انه
السعوديه بقى عندها طلب كثيره تخفض
الفائده والدولار الامريكي هيضطر في
النهايه انه يقلل الفايده هيحصل عمليه
تعادل يعني
ما اعتقدش ان امريكا هتضطر تعمل كده لان
عمرها ما حصلت يعني لكن اوتوماتيكل بما ان
السعوديه هتزود الفائده بعد شويه صغيرين
هتلاقي انه
هي بتقلل لانك خدت احتياجاتها وهيحصل
عمليه التعادل وما بين السعوديه يعني احنا
فاضل لنا اربع
هناك تطور في شان الظواهر الجويه المجهوله
ومتابعه من الكونجرس التشريعات جديده انا
عملت حلقه ده اللي كنت اعرفه ما عنديش
حاجه تاني ممكن اضيفها لو حضرتك تحب
تشوفها لان انا المساله دي يعني فيها كتير
من الاسرار اللي هم محتفظين بها لانفسهم
هل فيها ما فيش بس انا وضعت فيها كل ما
اعلمه في حلقه اللي هي الاجسام الفضائيه
ديت والغريبه ان المشكله دي دائما بتظهر
لما تكون في ازمات دوليه وما اعرفش بقى
بيوظفوها ازاي وايه اهدافهم يعني
مرحبا اخي الفاضل ما هي اكثر اجابنا عليها
الناس ستذكر ان هو الشخص الذي قرر عدم
دخول موسكو واراقه الدماء وان بوتين في
الحقيقه كان ضعيفا
وهو من او عزل لكوشينكو اللي هو رئيس
بيلاروس لاستجداء بروجوجن
ان بوتين
ان بوتين نمره من ورق وهذا الانقلاب اول
مسمار فينا 10 روسيا يعني بوسه معتصم
القصه
حتى فيها تفاصيل كثيره مش واضحه انما انا
مش هذهب الى الحد اللي انت ذهبت اليه اولا
لانه رئيس بيلاروس قال اللي هو قال انه
بوتين مرر اليه الرساله التاليه وانا
مررتها ارجع الى ادراجك
والا سوف افعصك كما تفعص الحشره ده كلام
ده واحد ده كلام للكوشينكو بعد ما قال
وانه
استدار فورا وعاد ثم خرج من هذه القصه بعد
ان
عرض عليه ما يشبه اللجوء
ثم انه يعني دهمت مقراته وصدرت امواله
وصفيت شركاته كما
حدث لاحقا فما اعتقدش اللي انت بتقوله
يعني طبعا حصلت اساءه وحصلت فيه مشكله لكن
فكره انه
يعني مستجده مش عارف مش متاكد وعموما
المسائل لسه هتتضح في الفتره المقبله
الوضع الحالي وزياره وزير الخارجيه
الاردني الى سوريا
ليس لدي تفاصيل هل حضرتك تنتمي لحزب سياسي
لا ابدا خالص ابدا هل تقترع علي ان انضم
الحزب السياسي على حسب البلد اللي انت
موجود فيها لو كنت انت عايش في مصر زي ما
انا بستنتج فلا انصحك يعني بصراحه يعني لا
اجد ان في احزاب سياسيه حقيقيه فعاله
وليها قاعده وموجوده ومع وافر الاحترام
للاحزاب اللي موجوده مش عاوز اظلمهم كلها
ولكنها احزاب ورقيه ضعيفه جدا مش عارف وضع
الدول العربيه الاخرى زينين برده مش عارف
لانه كثير من الدول العربيه ما فيش فيها
احزاب او احزاب اشكالها بسيطه جدا انا اسف
انه مرت الساعه بشكل سريع
ان شاء الله
بعتذر جدا للاصدقاء اللي انا لم اجد وقتا
للاجابه على اسئلتهم انا اسف والله انا
مضطر يعني لختم الحلقه يعني
لكن ان شاء الله في المرات الجايه يكون
عندنا وقت اطول وعاوز من حضراتكم اللي
ده سؤال تاني يعني انا ممكن اعمل عليه
الاستفتاء انا حقيقي يعني مش متاكد قوي من
مساله المباشر
هل هو فعلا مجدي بحيث ان احنا نستمر فيه
قولولي بامانه يعني يعني انا مقدر اللياقه
ممكن تكون بعض الاصدقاء المحترمين وقولوا
لي كويس وكذا بس ما احنا لو ما فيش مباشر
ما احنا عندنا الحلقات الاخرى فاكون شاكر
جدا لان احنا في حاله نقاش مع ماندو مع
عمرو ومع اصدقائي هنا هل ده جيد هل اللي
احنا بنعمله ده بهذا الشكل جيد ولا لا ان
احنا نستغنى عن المباشر خالص ونعود الى
حلقتنا كما كانت وربما بشكل مكثف اكثر ولا
هو جيد بس يبقى مره كل اسبوعين مره كل شهر
مره كل اسبوع اذا ارسلتوني وخصوصا لما
نكتب اعمل يعني لو ارسلتوني باي وسيله
يعني سواء هنا على الخاص على الكمبيوتر
اكون شاكر جدا ان انا اسمع وجهه نظركم
واشكركم واعتذر طبعا الاسئله التي لم
استطع ان انا اجيبها وان شاء الله المره
القادمه المره القادمه يكون في متسعه
الاجابه على هذه الاسئله اشكركم والى